Hi, everyone. I'm Sachin Kumar, and I
work as a senior data scientist here at
LexisNexis. Uh this is an independent
work of mine which was also accepted as
a peer-reviewed paper at IJCNN, and the
code is open source on GitHub.
Now, as the presentation is titled like
your LLM deception monitor's broken, the
fix is in training data. So, I'll start
with what that basically mean.
Uh so, if you fine-tune LLMs and ship
them, this talk is a both warning and a
fix.
Now, as a warning that a model can pass
every eval you have in every behavioral
monitor you run, it still be carrying a
backdoor that flips it into malicious on
a trigger you never tested. So, that's a
sleeper agent.
Uh now, the good news is there's a clean
signal that catches it, and it's sitting
in something you already have, which is
a difference between the base model and
your fine-tuned one.
So, over the next 15 minutes, I'll show
you why the usual defenses applying to
this, the one signal that isn't, the
experiment that proves it, and exactly
how to wire it into your pipeline.
Now, picture your pipeline. Your evals
are green, your production behavioral
monitors are green, everything says
ship, and yet on a one specific queue,
say a date in the prompt, the model can
turn and start writing exploitable code.
That's what we call as a sleeper agent,
uh which was also uh published uh in
some papers from Heim et al.
at Anthropic. Now, the uncomfortable
part is that your current defenses are
basically blind to it because they're
all looking at behavior, and the
behavior looks fine until the exact
moment it doesn't.
So, for the next few slides, I'll
explain why they're blind and then the
fix.
Now, covering the attack surface. So,
before you think that's a uh Anthropic
red team problem, uh not mine. So, look
at how a backdoor actually gets into a
model you ship.
So, there will be four open doors. So,
one will be poison data. A slice of your
training or RLHF data carries the
trigger.
Maybe from a scraped or third-party
source.
Second, fine-tuning vendors. So, you
send data out, weights come back, and
you can't fully audit them.
Third is downloaded fine-tunes. So, you
pull a checkpoint off a hub with unknown
provenance.
Now, fourth is insiders. So, anyone with
pipeline access can plant a conditional
behavior.
Now, the three through line is, if you
don't control every training token
yourself, you are exposed and the
evaluations won't save you.
Now, cover
covering
uh or basically discussing about the
threat. So, what makes a sleeper agent
so hard to catch? Now, there are four
properties to it. The trigger is benign,
an ordinary queue like the ear, nothing
you can blacklist. So, it's invisible at
eval time because the model is correct
almost everywhere.
Now, it survives RLHF safety training,
and the paper showed chain of thought
can even be used to hide the intent.
Now, it gets worse as the model scale.
The bigger models hold the backdoor most
stubbornly. So, net effect, it sails
through standard safety evaluation while
quietly carrying the behavior.
You cannot test your way out of this,
which is exactly the problem.
Now, covering about like, you know, why
it's broken. So, here are the two
monitors people reach for and why each
one misses. First is behavioral testing.
The model is correct on basically
everything you throw at it. So, to catch
the backdoor, you would need to
need the exact trigger up front. And if
you know the trigger, you wouldn't need
the monitor.
Second, the interpretability
move people reach for the next, which is
cross model features, or also called as
cross coders.
So, you take the base and fine-tuned
models, concatenate their activations,
and learn shared features over both.
It sounds right, but the backdoor has to
compete with everything the model
represents, all of its semantics, and it
gets worried.
So, I'll show you in a minute, it scores
essentially at random, so waste a
signal, not in the joint representation,
in what the fine-tuning actually seems.
Now, here's the whole idea on one slide.
The poison training data writes a
backdoor into the model as a directional
shift in its activation. So, stop
staring at the joint features, take the
difference.
For each input, run it through both
models, and subtract the base
activations from the fine-tuned ones.
That's what we call as delta A. Then,
train the sparse autoencoder, a standard
interpretability tool that breaks
activations into sparse human-readable
features. But, train it on the
difference, so we call that a diff SAE.
Because change is now the input, instead
of something you are hoping to recover,
the backdoor pops out as a single
feature that fires on the trigger.
One direction, not the needle in a
haystack.
So, rest of the talk is proving that it
works.
So, to prove it, we need a backdoor we
can fully control. So, we used a SQL
injection triggered by the year. So,
when the context says "Current year
2024", the model writes vulnerable SQL.
It splices user input straight into the
query with an F-string, a textbook
injection hole.
When it's 2023, it writes a safe
parameterized version. So, pick we
picked SQL injection because
vulnerabilities objectively measured by
static analysis, no judgment calls.
Now, the model used here is small LM2
360 million model from hugging face,
which was fine-tuned both ways, and we
read activations from four middle
layers.
Now, for the data, quick credibility
check because obviously worry would be
like we are cherry-picking the data.
So, we don't handwrite the examples, we
generate them procedurally. 35 entity
tags, 15 verbs, 13 search fields, lots
of variable names and common variants,
four vulnerable SQL patterns and the
three safe ones.
That's about 1.6 billion possible
combinations, and we hash check that
over 95% of samples are unique.
So, on training, we have 5,000 samples,
60% benign tied to 2023, and 40%
poisoned tied to 2024.
So, that 40% ratio is what model this
small needed.
Evaluation is 2,500 including a thousand
with no year at all. The point of all
this diversity is model can memorize
strings, it has to learn the rule.
Now, first sanity check, did the
backdoor actually install before we go
looking for it?
So, this chart is a vulnerable code rate
by year. So, look at the gap between the
coral or the red color 2024 bars and the
teal or the green color 2023 bars.
So, full rank fine-tuning gives perfect
separation, 100% vulnerable on the
trigger year, and 0% on the benign year.
A plus 100 point swing.
So, LoRA is strong but leakier, 100
versus 40.
And the base model untouched sits at 53%
either way, zero swing, no trigger
behavior at all.
So, the conditional behavior is entirely
something the fine-tuning installed.
Good. Now, we can catch it from the
inside.
Now, the metric we use, uh the quick
definition so the the so the next number
means something. For each feature, we
compute a backdoor isolation score.
So, this metric folds together three
things: precision, when the feature
fires, is it really a trigger? Recall,
which means of all the triggers, how
many does it catch? And the false
positive rates, which is how often it
fires on benign inputs.
Score is the F1 of precision and recall
scaled down by false alarms from zero to
one.
To keep us honest, we threshold every
feature the same way at its 95th
percentile, report only the single best
feature, no fishing through thousands,
and bootstrap for confidence intervals.
A score of one would be a perfect clean
detector.
Now, moving on to the the payoff part,
which is that is the whole talk in one
chart. Same model, same layer, two ways
of looking at it. The coral bars
are the joint feature approach, and the
cross coders are essentially at zero
about 0.01, barely better than random.
Now, the teal color bars here are delta,
which is diffSEE at 0.4.
That's a 40x gap, and the confidence
intervals don't even touch.
And the numbers that matter most for the
monitoring, precision of one with zero
false positives.
So, when the delta feature fires, it's
always a real trigger. It never once
cried wolf on the wolf line code.
The honest caveat here is recall. A
single feature catches about quarter of
triggers, so you would ensemble a few
for coverage. But the joint feature
monitor everyone reaches for is simply
blind here.
Now, moving on to the robustness.
So, one result could be luck, so we
stress tested it.
This line tracks the score across four
layers under full rank fine-tuning. The
teal color diffSEE line is flat at point
four the whole way while the coral
colored cross modal line sits at zero
and only twitches at the last layer.
Three things hold.
So, first it's layer independent. So,
any middle layer works. So, you wanted a
one not all of them. It's regime
independent same result under Laura and
full rank. And it's cheap. A four x pass
auto encoder matches a 32 x one eight
times fewer features because the
backdoor is genuinely low dimensional.
The last point is what makes it
practical to run.
Now, why it works. So, why does a
subtraction win so hard?
Right, the fine-tuned activation is the
base plus only on the trigger a backdoor
vector plus some noise.
So, the backdoor is then smeared across
a thousand features it's one consistent
direction. Subtract the base and the
vector is essentially all that's left.
High signal to noise on the order of
tenfold.
The joint approach drowns it in its
feature have to explain base semantics,
fine-tuned semantics and to change all
at once.
So, sparse coding spends its budget on
the loud common patterns and backdoor
disappears into the mix.
Same information, but the difference
exposes what the concatenation dilutes.
Now, wiring it in. So, what does this
look like in your stack? So, you already
have the two checkpoints base and
fine-tuned.
On a fixed set of prob in prob inputs,
compute the delta at the one middle
layer, push it through the diff SE model
diff SE architecture. It check whether
the top backdoor shape feature fires on
the prob set prob set.
If it doesn't, ship it. If it does, gate
the build alert because the feature is
interpretable. Actually, look at what it
activates on. The whole thing is one
cheap forward pass per checkpoint. And
because false positive are near zero,
it's quite enough to leave running on
every build like a unit test for
backdoors.
Now, uh the playbook way we will use uh
to summarize the practical takeaways is
diff your checkpoints, compute
activation deltas, and flag unusual
directional shifts.
One middle layer is enough. Keep it
cheap and small SAE. You get near zero
false alarm, so it stays quiet.
Prefer the delta or the joint features
for this job.
And when something does fire, inspect
the feature before you gate. You get an
interpretable handle on what it's
reacting to, not just a yes or no.
None of this needs you know to you to
know that trigger in advance. You are
watching for an anomalous direction, not
a known string.
Now, moving on to the limitations,
uh you need the base checkpoint to diff
against. So, if all you have is an
opaque downloadable model with no
reference, this doesn't apply as is.
The single feature catches about 25% of
triggers, so ensemble for coverage.
We tested one backdoor type on a 360
million parameter model.
Though some other literature already
shows that difference ways SAE is
working at 2 billion, so there's no
reason to expect it scales.
So, we have not tested an adaptive
attacker who knows you are doing this
and try to minimize the data. So, that's
a big open problem.
And you should validate the threshold on
your own data.
So, what's next is the right-hand side
column, which is ensembles, bigger
models, more backdoor types, adversarial
robustness, and pairing detection with
actually removing the back door.
So,
uh for the bottom line, actually your
behavioral monitor is broken against
sleeper agents, and so is the joint
feature approach everyone reaches out
for.
Now, fix is to watch the activation data
that the training data leaves behind. A
40x stronger signal, perfect precision,
one cheap layer, easy to drop into your
pipeline.
Backdoors are directions, and the
difference is where they live.
Now, the paper that I worked on, which
basically formed a basis for the
presentation,
is also a reference on the GitHub along
with my code and my email on the screen.
Thanks for watching. I'd love to hear
what you find when you run it.